on va parler de la présidentielle
puisque c'est valérie pécresse a donc
était désignée elle a été élue samedi
candidate des républicains pour la
présidentielle mais après la belle photo
de famille samedi le siège des
républicains eric ciotti a déjà commencé
à annoncer les premiers tacles jonathan
du ps
l'unité dlr commence déjà à se fissurer
au lendemain de sa victoire au congrès
du parti valérie pécresse a d'ores et
déjà balayée de reprendre à son compte
les propositions les plus musclés de son
ex rival éric ciotti comme la création
d'un guantanamo à la française ou encore
la priorité nationale pour les emplois
et le logement la candidate entend
imposer son programme je ne l'accepterai
pas je ne vais pas le dénaturer c'est le
projet que les adhérents choisi
maintenant si on peut lui rajouter j'ai
vu que que marine le pen nous parlait
par les quatre quarts si on peut
rajouter un zeste de citron ou un zeste
de vanille pour pimenter le 4/4 et
qu'ils soient encore meilleurs et bien
je le ferai un positionnement qui a fait
bondir eric ciotti assurant que le
message lancé par valérie pécresse
n'était pas le bon avec 39% des voix au
second tour du congrès la ligne ciotti a
été confortée au sein de l air le député
des alpes-maritimes entend ainsi mettre
la pression sur valérie pécresse pour
que ces idées très droitière infuse dans
le projet présidentiel
valérie pécresse devra donc faire le
grand écart garder dans son giron une
franche du camp ciotti tenter de
rejoindre eric zemmour elle devra aussi
convaincre le centre droit de ne pas
basculer vers la macro ni pour ses
soutiens son profil saura rassembler la
famille politique dans son ensemble
et finalement relativement assemblée sur
son programme et donc il y aura pas de
problème de création de ce programme de
la campagne présidentielle
de leur côté les entourages de valérie
pécresse et d'eric ciotti assure qu'il
n'ya aucun problème entre les deux
finalistes du congrès signe de cette
unité affichée valérie pécresse se rend
aujourd'hui sur les terres d'eric ciotti
dans l'arrière-pays niçois
cette dernière heure ça montre que le
plus dur commence pour valérie pécresse
et que finalement l'unité n'est
peut-être que de façade ça va être
compliqué pour elle de rassembler sa
famille sur le fond c'est compliqué
parce que si vous voulez finalement
l'équation qu'elle à erize à résoudre
c'est l'équation qui est l'équation des
républicains depuis 2010 est comment je
fais pour ramener dans la maison des
républiques cet électorat de
centre-droit qui est attiré par emmanuel
macron et comment je fais pour amener
dans la maison des républicains cet
électorat de droite qui lui a dit qu'à
voter eric ciotti lors du congrès et qui
est attiré par les offres politique
d'eric zemmour et par l'offre politique
de marine le pen c'est à dire que en
effet attiré cet électorat de droite de
la droite c'est prendre le risque de
perdre l'électorat de centre-droit et
attirer l'électorat de centre-droit
c'est prendre le risque de perdre
l'électorat de droite de la droite ce
que je dis d'une trivialité absolument
facebook à l'équation à laquelle ils
sont confrontés moi je pense quand même
que le veut juste un point que le vrai
sujet savez françois mitterrand avait
l'habitude de dire que pour gagner une
élection il faut dans un premier temps
rassembler son camp
le vrai défi aujourd'hui pour valérie
pécresse c'est de rassembler son camp à
droite et aussi à la droite de la droite
moi je pense qu'elle a commis une petite
erreur lors du journal de tf1 en faisant
part de ses réserves voire de ses
réserves de son opposition c'est pas le
fait qu'elles soient opposés c'est pas
le fait que finalement je dirais ne
veulent pas prendre cette mesure à son
compte mais il ne fallait pas le dire à
la télévision de cette façon là ça se
prépare ce genre de chose en général oui
pour un arnaud a tout dit et bien dit
mais seulement fait quantifier ce qui
vient se dire charger sur cette guerre
sur deux fronts que va devoir jouer
valérie pécresse en actes dans une
logique que c'est vrai le premier tour
on rassemble son camp son corps est
double premier tron c'est 20 % des
lecteurs de françois fillon qui dans les
intentions de vote sont en soutien du
président de l'aje de la république
c'est presque 50% lors les enquêtes de
popularité et puis du côté de la droite
de la droite c'est 10% d'électeurs
fillon qui vont chez le pen 20% chez
eric zemmour ce qui exclut que pour
l'instant on verra bien sûr si un effet
désignation même si c'est pas la même
impulsion qu'une primaire de quatre
millions cinq cent mille personnes on
était sur une sur un congrès beaucoup
plus restreint de pouvoir faire revenir
c'est ce qui explique que pour 1 6%
d'intentions de vote soit là dessus et
frédéric parce que c'est intéressant à
partir de quand on va le voir cet effet
de désignation nous aurons des enquêtes
très très bientôt à l'ifop mais ce qui
est très important de voir c'est si
y'aura s'était fait d'impulsion françois
hollande après le congrès après la
primaire ouverte socialiste gagne 3,4
points françois fillon en 2016 parce que
ils partaient beaucoup plus bas parce
que ça a été une une surprise aït ouamar
cela dit même si la dynamique avaient
été vus gagne 6 à 7 points des
intentions de vote on verra sans doute
que la puissance sur un mois faute parce
que c'est pas le c'est pas la même
dynamique elle n'a parlé surtout qu'à
des militants qu'à ses 120 mille
adhérents mais c'est vrai et arnaud le
dit très bien cette guerre sur deux
fronts peut être très compliqué puisque
engager des paroles fortes une offre
dramatiques sur un front peut
automatiquement
déplaire à l'autre et donc faire revenir
des électeurs fillon soit du côté macro
soit du côté d'avoir deux à droite mais
ça veut dire qu'il va devoir choisir
entre les deux camps et pourra pas tenir
oui alors il y aura aussi hélas on ne le
sait pas les circonstances de campagne
série quand on note quand on entend le
meeting d'eric zemmour on voit qu une
droitisation une radicalité elle ne
pourra pas ne pas répondre à cette
radicalité et puis elle a un aiguillon
moins fort que l'aiguillon rousseau pour
jadot mais l'aiguillon ciotti est peut
être un vrai caillou dans la chaussure
et c'est vrai que le décalage entre ces
images d' union parfaite des perdants
extrêmement bons joueurs cette belle
photo de samedi et ce qui s'est passé
hier est quand même assez saisissant
ouais on va parler d'eric zemmour dans
quelques instants mais d'abord pierre
sueur sur ce décalage
on parlait au frédéric et sur cette
difficulté de concilier à la fois de
ramener les électeurs centristes c'est
de ramener les électeurs tentés par
évidemment
oui moi je suis quand même assez assez
sévère avec valérie pécresse le score de
samedi je ne sais pas 51 40 alors certes
c'est un petit bon gré sur un petit
panel de votants mais valérie pécresse a
quand même un peu plus à mon sens les
mains libres que ce qu'on veut le croire
simplement elle va avoir évidemment un
problème de ligne et maintenant c'est
bien d'avoir gagné un congrès de
militants mais il va falloir parler aux
français ils notamment à cette droite
mais celle qui a attiré par eric zemmour
oui mais surtout ramener ceux qui ont
voté emmanuel ma seule qui sont partis
et qui ont voté manuel macron en 2010
elle je pense que le plus gros du vivier
a amené à rattraper et là pour valérie
pécresse et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
c'est la candidate qui inquiète plus ou
en tout cas qui arrange le moins un
exécutif et le président de la
république qui s'était depuis des
semaines préparer à affronter xavier
bertrand tu arrivé derrière michel
barnier donc valérie pécresse je pense
pas qu'elle ait tant les mains liées que
ça simplement il va falloir qu'elle
trouve
comment dire qu'elle compose et qu'elle
trouve qu'elle est sa droite quelle est
la droite qui parlera plus aux anciens
électeurs partis vers la macro ni
chances que le deal est là et je ne
pense pas que valérie pécresse puisse
ramener au sein des républicains
ni personne tentée par le discours des
régimes je crois je pense que ces
personnes-là temps partie des
républicains et ne feront pas le chemin
inverse alors que les maquereaux nice
c'est peut-être le frédéric dabi me
contredira mèche c'est à mon sens
beaucoup plus volatile
je suis pas en désaccord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit il ya la campagne qui
va donner le tempo qui va montrer là où
il ya le vivier le plus important c'est
vrai que pour l'instant ce qui me frappe
c'est à quel point le socle des mailles
macron ne bouge pas ça fait un an qu'on
tente de popularité autour de 40% avec
sa capacité à faire revenir vers lui
trois quarts de son électorat vendent 20
à 25% délectera fillon de l'électorat de
gauche mais c'est vrai que il n'est pas
candidat descendre dans l'arène c'est
peut-être le fragiliser et c'est vrai
que quand on entend et là je peux être
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit
par pierre quand on entend les premiers
mots de veiller de manière des graisses
elle s'inscrit systématiquement en
distinction par rapport à melle macron
pour justement déjeuné se fend droit
distinction je suis une élue locale il
est il et deux nuls par distinction je
suis une femme le temps des femmes et tu
arrives et distinctions il a cramé la
caisse mois à la région ile de france
j'ai réussi à faire des économies
importantes et puis quand on voit une
mesure qu'elle a qu'elle a annoncé la
réforme des retraites à 65 ans ça
sous-entend lui mails macro est un faux
réformateur de fameux et mario land dont
parlait françois fillon et il n'a pas
vraiment réformer c'est les axes et là
je je rejoins pire mais je pense que
l'électorat de droite qui va chez
zemmour n'est pas pour autant perdu
quand on voit peut-être sa crainte c'est
un électorat attaché à l'orgue à
sécurité si je puis dire la chienlit
autour du meeting d'eric zemmour et sur
la manière aussi m tunis a dit emmanuel
macron il est dans son obsession c'est
de plaire et rejoint ses deux femmes
tout à fait à un moment on va parler
justement des lames du positionnement
des républicains par rapport à eric
zemmour est grave dans les premières
heures qui ont suivi la victoire de
valérie pécresse il a appelé à lui les
électeurs d'eric ciotti il a fait
acclamer eric ciotti hier lors de son
meeting alors comment les républicains
comptent se positionner par rapport à
eric zemmour on va écouter les réactions
de certains d'entre eux auteuil
recueillies samedi au siège des
républicains par marion delpech et qui
enrôle durban il faut trouver le chemin
de le croisement entre trois lignes des
trois droites qui sont la droite qui
attachés à la liberté à l'autorité et
puis aux valeurs et thievery qui a
commencé à le faire pendant la campagne
des primaires continue pendant la
campagne présidentielle alors c'est
cette équation qui est gagnant la force
elle est chez nous la république elle
est chez nous les valeurs républicaines
elles sont chez nous et moi je m'occupe
pas de monsieur zemmour je m'occupe de
la france m'occupe du projet de valérie
pécresse et du projet de la droite
républicaine c'est tous ensemble
justement qu'on pourra réussir à
rassembler tous les électeurs de la
droite en france y compris ceux qui
pourraient être tentés par eric zemmour
ça va être compliqué ce positionnement
par rapport aux électeurs d'eric zemmour
quand on voit déjà loupé à qu'au temps
de me faire un examen sur ses électeurs
de droite mais c'est compliqué pourquoi
parce que il ya si vous voulez à
soupçons des ces séries t qui plane sur
la droite de gouvernement
il ya une partie de l'électorat qui se
souvient que il y avait nicolas sarkozy
en 2007 que la droite a gouverné avec
jacques chirac durant les années 2000 et
que tout un ensemble de sujets qui sont
aujourd'hui au coeur de l'agenda
politique ne donne pas l'impression
d'avoir été traité donc il ya une forme
de ressentiment qui s'est installé entre
une partie de l'électorat de droite et
cette droite de gouvernement et de ce
point de vue là eric zemmour ils le
disent on frappe là où ça fait très mal
quand il dit finalement cette droite là
depuis trente ans elle n'a fait que
trahir ses électrices et électeurs et on
voit que ça fonctionne dans un certain
nombre d'études de d'opinion qui sont
effectuées et le discours qu'il a tenu
hier je pense qu'on va y revenir et
trimestre qui était de fait un appel à
cet électorat de droite et faisait d'une
certaine manière ce constat de carence
de la droite ensuite l'autre problème
pour quand même juste pour valérie
pécresse ça va être le problème là aussi
c'est un problème de sincérité c'est
comment elles se différencient des
manuels macron je suis d'accord elle
propose d'aider finalement des options à
ces réformistes qui peuvent parler à une
partie de cet électorat d'emmanuel
macron qui est attaché au logiciel
réformisme et yen autre sujet qui est
essentiel pour la droite c'est d'aller
reconquérir les classes populaires et
comment elle fait pour aller reconquérir
les classes populaires aujourd'hui ça
c'est une vraie question à laquelle elle
n'a pas pour l'instant répondu oui pour
résumer ce que dit arnaud très justement
il ya une phrase qui risque de mouradi
lors du meeting qui résume tout valérie
pécresse promettre à tous et ne tient
dira ne tiendras rien c'est clairement
et d'ailleurs votre invité de tout à
l'heure je faisais à copé avait créé à
lift ses plaies le sursaut il raconté
que sur le terrain en 2016 les gens
disaient de toute façon à droite au
pouvoir ne fait pas ce qu'elle a dit et
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai point de
fragilité quand parallèlement emmanuel
macron est complètement épargné par la
critique des promesses non tenues qui
était très fort françois hollande n'a
levé sous la courbe du chômage qui était
absolument massive pour nicolas sarkozy
il a trahi de travailler plus pour
gagner plus et ça c'est un vrai en
attaque de ce point de vue là on va
continuer zemmour un meeting de
lancement de campagne de lancement de
son parti également audrey d'abord un
mot sur le contexte sur la forme et elle
est importante parce qu'il a été
émaillée de beaucoup de violences
février oui on savait que l'ambiance
allait être tendu un plusieurs
manifestations anti zemmour était
annoncée à l'extérieur de la salle de
villepinte le mit le meeting était
d'ailleurs classé à risques par les
forces de l'ordre et en effet à
l'intérieur on a assisté à un meeting
assez violent je pense que c'est le mot
avec des affrontements que vous allez
voir sur les images qu'on va vous
montrer tout démarre pas un happening de
militants antiracistes a fini en bagarre
générale et se font agresser par un
militant pro zemmour des personnels de
la sécurité et on a vu notamment une
jeune femme de sos racisme avec le
visage en sang certains journalistes ont
affirmé sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on
les avait violemment empêchés de filmer
et de rapporter cette scène on a aussi
vu une équipe de l'émission quotidien eu
et puis exfiltré dès le début du meeting
ils ont pu revenir dans la salle mais ça
montre l'ambiance et je pense que c'est
important de le souligner c'est
extrêmement rare voire jamais vu dans un
meeting et puis il y a les mots et dans
son discours eric zemmour a multiplié
les attaques contre les médias contre
les journalistes pas moins de quinze
référence contre la presse dans les 30
premières minutes écoutez un très court
extrait
s'il me méprise c'est un style vous mais
présent
contre moi contre moi tout est permis la
meute est désormais lancée à mes
trousses mes adversaires veulent ma mort
politique les journalistes veulent ma
mort sociale et les djihadistes bonne
maman tout court on va évidemment parler
de ce climat un violent je vous le
disiez envers des militants d'assurer ce
récit eric zemmour lui-même qui a été
violemment agrippé quand il se rendait
sur scène
lors de lors de ce meeting qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça dit de ce début du
climat ça dit que de toute façon le
débat politique le débat public devient
de plus en plus complexes dont la
société française on voit que il ya
quand même pour le veuille ou non une
montée en tension à la fois sur le plan
physique et sur le plan sémantique qui
caractérise ces derniers mois de la vie
publique en france alors ensuite bon si
vous voulez le discours anti
journalistes moi je pense que eric
zemmour en effet ils l'utilisent parce
que tout simplement quand on regarde
aussi les études d'opinion on voit bien
que malheureusement le monde des médias
est aussi associée au monde des élites
et qu'il ya un profond pied un profond
sentiment anti élites qui s'est
installée dans la société française mais
il n'est pas le seul à le faire et ça
avait déjà été fait il faut se souvenir
durant la campagne présidentielle de
2017 ou la plupart des candidats à
l'exception peut-être des manuels
maquereau en l'occurrence il faut lui
bob pour porter sa son crédit la plupart
des candidats avaient eux-mêmes émis un
certain nombre de critiques sur la
fonction sur le fonctionnement du
système médiatique je rappelle que jean
luc mélenchon parler en parlant des
médias de la deuxième peau du système
donc c'était quand même des critiques
très méfiant et on l'a vu on l'a vu
encore récemment on voit bien que par
exemple madame hidalgo lorsqu'elle est
face à face à des avec des journalistes
n'hésitent pas à leur dire vos questions
sont débiles eux donc disons il ya il y
à climat anti médiatique qui n'est pas
le monopole d'eric zemmour même si eric
zemmour et celui peut-être qu'ils
portent le plus loin et le plus
fortement cette critique oui il la porte
extrêmement fortement j'ai retrouvé la
rhétorique de jean marie le pen le eux
et nous le à travers moi à travers leur
mépris c'est vous qui méprisent et puis
ce discours jean marie le pen s'était
l'établissement la slack la caste
politico médiatique et sondagière on met
tout le monde dedans eux et nous la
bande des quatre est là on a retrouvé sa
dimension mais avec une virulence et une
violence verbale qui était beaucoup plus
forte que celle de jean marie le pen
notamment lorsque eric zemmour attaques
le président de la république a bien sûr
le droit de le faire mais quand il parle
de vide le néant il n'est personne on a
vraiment eu un meeting avec une violence
verbale qu'on avait jamais rarement vu
et tout ça est une crise une campagne
avec en plus je le disais le spectre que
cette campagne soit confisquée par de
nouvelles restrictions liées à la
pandémie sur le fond puisque on
attendait évidemment de ce premier
meeting des propositions d'un examen
début de programme qu'est ce qu'il a dit
aux autres bon alors sans surprise c'est
un programme à droite voire très à
droite sur l'immigration bien évidemment
l'immigration zéro deviendra un objectif
clair de notre politique c'est ce qu'il
a dit plus précisément il est pour la
suppression du droit du sol contre le
regroupement familial et pour
l'expulsion immédiate des délinquants
étrangers eric zemmour qui a aussi
annoncé qu'ils voulaient sortir la
france de l'otan comme avait pu le faire
le général de gaulle à l'époque et puis
sur le volet économique il souhaite
supprimer les droits de succession pour
la donation des entreprises familiales
alléger la fiscalité et il veut
réindustrialiser la france ils
s'emparent aussi et enfin je dirais d'un
sujet de préoccupation majeure des
français le pouvoir d'achat écoutez
je réduirai donc les cotisations qu'ils
payent afin de rendre chaque année un
treizième mois aux salariés touchant le
smi
chaque mois
c'est chaque noix
plus qu'ils recevront sur ces
propositions effectivement les attendait
la balayer plusieurs thèmes là pour le
coup à qui sa part on a l'impression ou
dit ce que je caricature un peu que
c'est à droite sur l'économie est très
très à droite sur les valeurs faire
l'immigré oui mais tout à fait d'accord
c'est ça c'est cette double cette double
orientation alors ce discours sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur le trait sur le
travail s'adresse à la france du travail
à la france du salariat qui a quitté la
droite depuis 2007 depuis la déception
il faut travailler plus pour gagner plus
cette france du salariat c'est le à la
seule zone de frottement entre le vote
macro et de vote le pen ces deux votes
extrêmement différent et complètement ou
presque complémentaires mais le salariat
c'est là où il ya une vraie bataille et
c'est vrai que eric zemmour ne pourra
pas seulement rester sur les thématiques
et régalienne il doit faire sa mue il
doit est attendu comme un candidat à
part entière et dans ce cadre là il doit
parler de ces questions là valérie
pécresse aussi à cet enjeu ce qui est
très intéressante avec tout ce que l'on
vient de voir ses il ya une sorte de
magot c'est cet électorat de droite
c'est à dire la droite qui est chez
makro la droite qu'est sheller la droite
extrême et moore et la droite de la
droite marine le pen et les quatre
candidats vont devoir faire assaut pour
essayer de faire revenir dans son giron
cet électorat droite notamment pas
seulement avec du un gagnant nicolas
sarkozy avait gagné sur ses deux jambes
disons cité nationale il travaillait
plus jeunes et des plus et donc dans le
cas dans ce cadre là ces mesures
sociales doivent vont à mon avis être
très fortement évoquée
enfin le meeting d'hier il avait trois
objectifs pour eric zemmour d'abord il
fallait réussir la mobilisation
des militants et de ce point de vue
force est de constater que quand même ça
a été plutôt jaillir l'objectif ait
atteint le deuxième objectif c'était
finalement 2 de faire cette mue c'est à
dire de passer du journaliste polémiste
a été dit mille fois à dix ont
finalement un candidat qui ait un
candidat qui apparaît en tout cas
crédible aux yeux de ceux qui vont le
regarder ce point de vue force est de
constater qu'il a plutôt réussi
l'exercice c'est à dire que il a montré
qu'il était capable notamment d'avoir un
certain nombre de capacités oratoires on
voit qu'il ya eu du travail derrière en
amont qui a été effectué le troisième
point c'est le programme sur le
programme et il ya eu une habileté qui
est rhétorique en l'occurrence c'est que
il n'a pas commencé par l'immigration
c'est ça qui est très intéressant dans
le discours qu'il a tenu il a commencé
par l'économique et le social donc d'une
certaine façon il a intériorisé le fait
qu'il y avait jusqu'à présent un certain
nombre d'angles morts dans son offre
politique
et de ce point de vue là force est de
constater que l'on partage ou que l'on
partage pas les opinions et les
positions d'eric zemmour que l'exercice
d'hier est plutôt un exercice qui
finalement a garroté cette impression
que sa campagne d'une certaine manière
était en train de partir en sucette
depuis quelques jours et là il a mis un
coup d'arrêt à cette impression et il
est d'une certaine façon me semble-t-il
à je peux me tromper mais revenu d'une
revenu pour partie dans la dans la
course et il exerce en effet une
pression très forte à la fois sur
l'électorat de marine le pen mais
également sur l'électorat de valérie
pécresse est la conclusion claire pour
vous c'est un pareil c'est
aussi le sens où effectivement on l'a
dit mille fois et c'est vrai dire on a
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
on avait plus un polémiste et il a
commencé à se rendre sur les terrains a
évoqué des thématiques sur lesquelles on
n'entendait pas avant ce qui lui était
reproché est l'un de ces défis
sans parler de la forme des violences
etc tout a été dit tout à l'heure
ces défis ça va être justement d'être
crédibles sur des sujets sur lesquels on
n'attend pas forcément d'où le ton quand
même
pro-entreprises gros travail a sévi pa
l'ont finalement finalement qu'on a
entendu hier et ce qui a permis je suis
d'accord avec arnaud de remettre entre
guillemets remettre dans le temps le jeu
en tout cas de la droite mais maintenant
il faut que je continue à aller sur des
thèmes sur lesquels on n'a pas
l'habitude de l'entendre ou en tout cas
sur des thèmes sur lesquels on ne sait
pas pour l'instant trop ce qu'ils
pensent et ce qu'il pense après je pense
que ça ça va être un petit peu plus
difficile à faire compte tenu du
contexte sanitaire qui va fortement
réduire les meetings les prochaines
semaines
[Musique]